it's a different situation than New York
it's a very difference in I get it and
what we had if we had nine are you mind
Betty please do you mind
yep go ahead where are you from by the
way Los Angeles well you see perhaps you
can do that in Los Angeles but this is a
district of columbia you see and and i'm
trying to make a point this is city
machinery and it's just draws some of
the councilmembers are looking to solve
problems that are not known to exist but
usually uber is one of the more
inventive transportation technologies at
the last decade it's a smartphone app
you can use to call a car it's proving
hugely popular here in washington DC but
it also was met with some staunch
regulatory opposition we're gonna talk
about what happened there
and what we find is going to reveal
something very very wrong with the way
the capital city of the most powerful
country in the planet runs itself the
cab industry here hadn't really changed
at all ever the attitude for the longest
time has been there there like a utility
being regulated like any other basically
public monopoly those are not the most
innovative businesses in the world that
if you held them on the street there's a
chance they won't pick you up or there's
a chance will tell you to get lost if
you tell them that you want to go across
town under cover of darkness
DC's taxis get worse this driver stopped
by but denied our Southeast DC
destination request he's got to go pick
up to white passage oh yeah I got the
white girls I can pick okay basically
for those who don't know we are an
on-demand town car service
our motto is everyone's private driver
take out your smartphone push a button
and a car appears within minutes and
when you get to your destination you get
out it's cashless it is 10 times better
the dirty filthy DC cabs convenient I
love getting text messages on many cabs
outside and now more and more people
turning to the enormous ly popular and
still expanding uber a lot more people
now doing this instead of this when it
comes to getting a cab so uber takes off
and the local regulators step in I'd
like you to meet Ron Linton he's the
head of the DC taxicab Commission I like
Ron he's charmingly eloquent and
avuncular I feel like he would tell
excellent scary stories at the last
campfire a Boy Scout camp I've been in
in the public administration for 50
years won't go into my age but it
substantially greater than what 99.9% of
everybody else should go so there was a
sting operation he was the Mayflower
Hotel there was a sting nothing as
dramatic as years ago you recall with
Eliot Spitzer and the call girls Rommel
inhales and uber who gets in the car
hasn't taken Marah drops them at the
Mayflower Hotel where there's inspectors
raiding right thousand dollar tickets
sort of the first shot in the youever
wars and the council decides it needs to
take a roll
I initially had oversight of
transportation from the district until I
investigated the chair of the Council
for misuse of government resources and
then I no longer chaired the committee I
became chair of the Transportation
Committee so you know it fell to me and
I said we have to do something they
tried to set a floor on our pricing that
they have a minimum fare well of course
on the eve of our adopting this the head
of uber you know went how shall I say
sir thousand emails were sent by our
riders have received over five thousand
emails I got thousands startling email
campaign it was amazingly effective $15
minimum it is eliminated from the bill
nobody is flooding DC Council members
inboxes with thousands of emails saying
save the cab industry I can't believe
this uber thing is gonna come and ruin
it I know that you like to have you know
this is you know some sort of fight
we're not in a fight with you do you
understand that I'm not in a fight with
you so when you tell us how to do
business and you tell us we can't charge
lower fares offer a high quality service
also price you are fighting with us you
still want to fight so actually uh since
I'm over my time and I don't want to
fight with you I'm going to turn to
councilmember Bowser and and we can
pursue this later and with regulation
that included wide berth for companies
like uber wow that was impressive but
the fight is far from over
despite that resounding legislative
victory the taxicab Commission is still
pursuing a long laundry list of controls
on uber the first volley came earlier
this summer when the Commission
attempted ultimately unsuccessfully to
force uber to use a standardized credit
card processing machinery there was no
technical barrier for them receiving
their information that they had to
receive through the PSP therefore they
could integrate with it and not be
outside the system they didn't like that
the Commission is also looking to
institute annual review
of ubers mobile phone app we need to
look at what they're using as a handheld
device before they use it and once a
year to take a look to see that they
haven't substituted something else when
we weren't looking most importantly the
Commissioner is prohibiting the use of
smaller vehicles and taxi services
setting the minimum weight for vehicles
used as a sedan at thirty two hundred
pounds this regulation really really
matters because it effectively prohibits
uber X which is ubers lower-cost
new service that largely employs smaller
hybrid vehicles or as Commissioner
Linton explains in the obligatory opaque
in stilted lingo the embedded
bureaucracy would not allow a sedan
digital service company to use somebody
who owned a small Prius for sedan
service so what exactly is going on here
why is it that the local DC regulators
are hell-bent on still trying to fix
something that has shown no signs that
it needs to be fixed you might think
that's because local entrenched taxicab
industry representatives have co-opted
key law makers and are trying to use the
power of public policy to block out
competition you would be correct I'm a
fan of attacks in machine I've always
been and the browser's outraged about
our homegrown industry is hit hard but
uber wants to rule the world that's with
the 45 million dollars estimate is got
it Oh
in San Francisco California the current
operation is illegal but I don't think
that analysis does justice to the messy
reality of what happened here first of
all the push to protect the incumbent
cab industry isn't solely a function of
backroom deals part of the taxi
Commission's job is to protect the
industry as it exists actually in in our
statute
we're charged with assuring a
economically viable taxicab industry so
when Ron Linton is pushing for measures
that block out some of their competitors
he's not necessarily acting from a point
of corruption he might just be doing his
job we can't make decisions that allow
one element in the industry to upend all
the other elements and force vehicles
out of existence second of all over it's
not exactly pure in all of this so
here's the way things usually work in
the DC Council you have something you
want to do that requires some change pay
lobbyists penny hundreds of dollars an
hour go set up some meetings down at the
Wilson building and he hammer it out and
uber actually did that they hired a
lobbyist they've hired several lobbyists
in fact the regulation ended up
requiring that you did have to have a
licensing well this was great to over
because Weaver was the first to get that
license but there are other models out
there sidecar effectively allows anyone
to carpool they don't require licensing
they sort of stepped inside this
regulatory velvet rope and then put it
up right right behind a third this
exclusive focus just on bad intentions
doesn't appropriately account for the
role of good intentions in office
Ron and many other members of the
regulatory establishment here suffer
from what I like to call the
accidentally oppressive conceit of
technocratic tinkering to find the
appropriate balance so that the person
buying gets decent service for a fair
price and the person selling gets a fair
return on investment in labor they think
that they can top-down engineer their
way towards more fair and just outcomes
it's like a teeter totter
you're always looking to move the
fulcrum to balance the two major
competing interests and in this push to
engineer more just outcomes there
accidentally hamstrung the ability of
local businesses to innovate and grow
regulation has been done in the interest
of the general public at the expense of
businesses large and small
small business owners are neck-and-neck
with Jesus as the most fetishized beans
in American politics but right here in
the city that federal politicians come
to do their work it's increasingly tough
to be one
ah my final point is that the City
Council has created a major national
security breach with a large number of
unregulated SUVs and SUV drivers now
operating for hire in the district it is
simply a matter of time until a
terrorist organization uses a few of
them packed with explosives to kill
large numbers of people large numbers of
such vehicles parked under the
Convention Center during the
Congressional Black Caucus activities
and/or the large numbers permitted to
drive in the drive entry areas of the
city's most favorite most fashionable
hotels should send chills down the backs
of every person in this room and this is
verified by the photo exhibit that you
have been given and I think that the
regulation of the sedans is absolutely
necessary
thank you